le dérèglement climatique et maintenant
perceptible par tous à l'échelle
mondiale au cours des six premiers mois
de l'année les catastrophes climatiques
ont poussés à l'exode près de 10
millions de personnes
mais paris qui s'est positionné en
leader de la lutte pour le climat sur la
scène internationale a bien des
difficultés à réduire ses propres
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le secteur des transports qui est le
plus émetteur en france elles n'ont pas
baissé depuis plus de dix ans
du côté de l'agriculture devenu le
deuxième secteur émetteur en 2019
ces émissions stagne pour ce qui est du
bâtiment il consomme toujours beaucoup
trop d'énergie avec des politiques de
rénovation des logements inefficaces les
cent des ménages face à des factures de
chauffage trop élevé selon
l'observatoire climat énergie en 2019 la
france et mis 414 millions de tonnes
équivalent co2 en hausse de 2 7% par
rapport à ses objectifs sur cette année
et nombreux sont ceux qui pointent du
doigt le double discours du président
emmanuel macron qui tantôt se place en
défenseur du climat tantôt en défenseur
de l'énergie nucléaire qui serait la clé
pour lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique selon lui le nucléaire c'est
de l'emploi et de l'énergie je ne suis
pas anti nucléaire je les ai toujours
dit avec beaucoup de force
nous on produit une électricité qui est
parmi elles les plus décarbonés au monde
grâce à quoi
grâce au nucléaire j'ai besoin du
nucléaire
si je le ferme demain qu'est ce que je
fais de son côté l'association
greenpeace ne cache pas sa déception
sous la présidence d manueel macron le
pays de l'accord de paris est
malheureusement en train de perdre son
rang dans la lutte contre le changement
climatique
cette combinaison de défaillances tend
sur les résultats concrets que sur les
moyens mobilisés décridibilise
aujourd'hui la parole des manuels macron
sur l'enjeu climatique et l' influence
française sur la scène internationale
quelque part nous avons déjà perdu le
combat climatique
le président de la république avait
promis de donner sans filtre leurs
propositions au législateur or un
certain nombre semble être remis en
cause
il faut faire très attention à ce que
les promesses soient tenues
paradoxalement la crise sanitaire aura
eu du bon les émissions de co2 d'origine
fossile ont connu une baisse record de 7
% en 2020 des résultats liés aux mesures
de confinement prises contre l'épidémie
de kobe 19 selon le bilan annuel du
global carbon project finalité de ce
mauvais bilan pour la france
en novembre le conseil d'état donné
trois mois aux gouvernements pour rendre
compte de ses actions en matière de
lutte contre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre la décision de la plus
haute juridiction administrative a été
salué par les défenseurs de
l'environnement
reste à savoir si elle au moins sera
entendu à l'elysée